we should say that most of Iran is she
and those are that's a branch of Islam
she's them yes let's maybe just briefly
linger sheism and and Sunni what what
just let's not get into it
let's do a one sentence summary uh and
that maybe which which is what most of
Iran is majority of the population of
the Muslim world are sunnis that's a
these are mainstream if you like to call
that actually means that kind of a
Ministry
can you actually Linger on the the Sunni
Sunnah
she she uh she means a party means those
that belongs to a party of Ali which was
goes back to the early Islamic history
of seventh century I mean I'm almost
lingering to the silly notion of
pronunciation and stuff like that so
yeah yeah means part like what what is
the extra eye at the end yeah
means belonging to this community yeah
she am is a person
are you Asia yes I miss you yeah and she
is the community community and in
English when it was anglicized it
becomes Shiite so if you say Shiite in
today it's perfectly acceptable and of
course I myself in my writings I always
a switch between one and the other one
of my books is always Shiite the other
book is always she and that hasn't been
settled but the Sheep population is the
smaller compared to the Sunni population
in the world in the world in the world
but in Iran is the opposite the Iran and
Iraq and possibly not Lebanon are the
three countries who barely Iraq and the
Lebanon have barely majority population
whereas Iran is a large population due
to its history of conversion to shizen
that by itself is another story but uh
in the sense that the the way that
historically it evolved the center
became Moshi
and the peripheries remained certainly
so you have communities of the baluch in
the south east
we have the Kurds a large portion of the
Kurds or sunnies
they have cheese as well then they have
the indigenous religion of their own
ideal uh what's called which is the
religion of indigenous to Kurdistan
there are two commands in the north east
of Iran who are also Chinese the other
communities the horizontal region in the
in the peripheries of Afghanistan they
are also Chinese and you have some Arab
population Arab speaking population in
the hosestan province in the southwest
of Iran which is also all across the
Persian Gulf